j'accueille maintenant lui simon
liberati
[Musique]
ray lema même chose pour moi
voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça va aller
qui crache l'état paul biya s'est couché
mathis a fait d'eux des plus beaux
endroits
simon liberati votre premier roman
anthologie des apparitions chez
flammarion fait beaucoup parler je
dirais même que tout le monde en parle
c'est le cas de le dire voilà alors le
pitch je vais le faire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
[Applaudissements]
n
[Musique]
c'est fait
alors le pitch était attentes et son
éditeur toi une telle admiration pour
simon que jeune mike louche je ne peux
exprimer
je peux je peux pas m'exprimer sans
pleurer sur son livre blanc mais c'est
un très beau livre bien sûr achevé le
pitch d'accord alors c'est l'histoire de
claude et de sa soeur marina durant la
dolce vita des années 70 le palace le
studio 54 saint tropez ibisa voilà et
aujourd'hui quand le livre commence
claude touche le rmi et marina a disparu
voilà c'est le pitch
il passe son temps à se demander où elle
est et il passe son temps à se remémorer
la bonne époque alors ce clou de ces
clichés inséminer dites-vous à la beauté
luciférienne qui nichent tonnes un peu
quoi qui fait partie d'une bande de de
pique-assiettes qui traînent autour des
autour des vip au tour des stars j'avais
un ami anglais qui avait une bonne
expression pour ça c'était watch bin
c'est à dire que c'est pas les has been
puisque les has been tout le monde sait
ce qu'est ce que c'est a priori enfin en
tout cas je pense ici à tout le monde
sait mais wang bin ça veut dire ça
existe pas en anglais en fait il n'a pas
été et il se construit comme s'il avait
été quelque chose
voilà donc laissé quelques intégrité sa
vie mais qui n'a pu mentir aux
finalement qu'il trouve ça normal quoi
bein oui c'est normal parce qu'à partir
du moment où on vient d'un milieu un peu
un peu moyen puis qu'on n'a rien fait
pour devenir quelque chose
on devient malcorra chose voilà c'est
normal et on vit ça à peu près à peu
près bien grâce aux grasses en effet aux
assedic à ce genre de choses par
ailleurs après il a des souvenirs qui
lui permettent un peu de seins de vivre
dire qu'au début du bouquin il est mal
quand même effectivement et vit du rmi
est la fin avec un arabe qu'un arabe
raciste ouais ouais mais oui non mais
c'est là c est un garçon c'est el mout
bergame aurais pas rencontrés visconti
quoi donc c'est assez pathétique ouais
mais bon c'est arrivé à beaucoup de gens
un allemand et qui était assez joli
c'est ce qu'avait la lumière sur eux
comme ça qui était ravissant mais bon et
ils n'ont pas travaillé ils ont rien
fait du tout et finalement ils ont fini
très mal dans la poubelle et c'est un
peu son cas voilà et marina sa soeur
donc très jeune à l'âge de 12 ans elle
sort avec des talents hauts et des jupes
ras la foudre est vendue par son frère
des niches dont vous êtes expression
très joli c'est un baby tapez 1 ouais le
baby tapin mais ça ça vient de servir de
7,6 du très beau livre qui est moi
christiane f 13 ans droguée prostituée
il y avait deux baby ta part à berlin et
le baby tapin c'est en fait les gens
très jeunes qui se vendent parce qu'en
fait quand on quand on quand on a la
grâce on essaie de
de gagner un peu le ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une sorte de complexe d'être
attirés vers les dieux comme ça et ils
sont ils sont attirés vers la lumière
mais bon c'est comme des papillons de
nuit et puis c'est fini quoi ça brûle
voilà donc ces histoires de claude de
marina et puis elle est riche et puis à
la drogue
et puis à la frime et tout ça fait une
espèce de social grâce sur la grâce et
sur cette gloire que certaines personnes
on a l'âge de 15-16 ans et qu'elle ne
retrouve jamais c'est proustien sauf que
c'était des gens qui avaient pas
vraiment le sens des réalités dont qu'il
comprenait pas très bien comment ça
pouvait fonctionner et il y avait il y
avait des tas de gens qui tournait
autour d'eux comme des espèces de comme
des papillons autour de la lampe
vraiment finalement ils se sont fait
bouffer alors que la lampe en général
elle bouffe les papillons sont fait
bouffer par les papillons quoi voilà
alors on pense évidemment à evry 2 caven
de jean jacques fouroux de suite moi toi
non mais si j'en aurais tendance est
très forte
pourquoi vous avez édité ce bouquin
frédéric pour l'argent déjà non c
éditeur c'est un métier très pénible on
lit beaucoup de choses pas terrible et
et quand j'ai lu le texte de liberati je
me suis dit ce métier est une chance ce
métier est un honneur c'est tout ce que
j'ai à dire je sais que c'est tout ce
que vous avez à dire mais c'est la
révélation de la rentrée toute la
critique et elle a salué il ya ya pas un
journaliste qui n'est pas été inspiré
sert que des types qui d'habitude
écrivent peut-être pas des articles
passionnants se met à écrire mieux en
ayant lu son livre le talent est
contagieux en ce qui le concerne
voilà bon moi je dis je sais pas je
trouve que c'est c'est fantastique que
vous l'ayez invités il est très tard non
mais c'est important aussi parce que
c'est bon je lui dois je pense que
peut-être dans quelques décennies on
continuera de lire son livre et nous
tous on sera oublié vous avez d'autres
projets quels conseils vous lui
donneriez frédéric à simon liberati de
continuer à vivre
voilà c'est gentil ça oui parce que
c'est pas c'est pas toujours c'est pas
toujours ce qui ressort c'est face est
très charmant j'ai eu beaucoup de textes
magnifiques etc
mais j'avais l'impression que c'était un
peu d éloge funèbre est bon c'est vrai
que mon livre étant assez négatif et
donnant une image assez assez positive
de la destruction
on pouvait penser que bon voilà pourquoi
il est pourquoi il est là essayer de
vendre ce bazar qui après tout n'est
qu'un appel à se jeter par la fenêtre
quand même malgré tout quand on le lit
et
et bruce et c'est un peu là je crois je
crois que c'était là il y avait une
certaine forme de d'esprit c'est à cette
époque est constitué à penser que bon il
fallait il fallait y aller à fond et
voilà quoi donc c'est le livre un peu
qui rend hommage à un certain nombre de
gens qui sont plus là forcément il ya un
certain qu'ils ont disparu à certains
qui sont encore là mais qui sont plus
vraiment vraiment aussi jolie qu'ils
étaient à l'époque et et voilà c'est une
sorte de face et pas un hommage funèbre
mais c'est un hommage dans une série ce
qu'on peut dire s'il manque ce sont les
dernières années folles que qu'on ait
vécu ouais parce qu'il ya trois choses
qui ont tué à quand tu es la beauté à
ses statuts et la beauté des automobiles
c'est la sécurité le confort et
l'économie en gros un sa voiture elle
était belle tant qu'elle n'était pas
secure temps qu'elle n'était pas
confortable et wasquehal n'était pas
économique donc on peut voir ça à
travers les automobiles c'est le symbole
ses 1,80 et voilà c'est ça donc c'est
c'est une forme de lyrisme un peu
un peu à peu nostalgique mais pas voilà
je n'ai pas plus je rends hommage à un
certain nombre de personnes qui sont
plus là quoi alors on se demandait quel
était le livre de la rentrée c'est
celui-là c'est le livre de simon
liberati et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous il
m'était impossible eux